Mario started the day with five fire
flowers he used some and now only has
three left if you is the number of
flowers he's used we can write the
following equation how many fire flowers
did Mario use so he started with five he
uses some of them so we subtract the
number he used and he ends up with three
so there's a bunch of ways that you
could do it one ways you literally could
probably do this in your head hey I took
away some number from five and I got
three and you probably know hey well if
I take two away from five I'm gonna get
three so he used two flowers the other
way that you could think about doing it
is hey we got only four options here let
me substitute each of him in here maybe
I was able to do this one in my head but
if I had something more complicated let
me try out these choices so if he only
took a zero away to be 5-0 he'd still of
course be left with five if he took one
away then of course he'd only have he'd
have four left if he took three away
he'd have two left but if he took two
away five minus two is indeed three and
the third way you learned this as we go
into more more of how of the how of
algebra and also the Y is that you could
systematically solve it but we'll go
into that in future videos so he used to
fire flowers